[Applaus]
[Musik]
von einem solchen abenteuer hp stets
geträumt
[Musik]
venedig canal grande hier beginnt meine
fantastische reise
auf einer berner örtlichen routen der
seidenstraße folge ich den spuren und
dem mythos des venezianischen händler
und abenteurers marco polo
[Musik]
meine reise führt mich von venedig nach
istanbul
quer durch den südlichen kaukasus dort
zentralasien bis in chinesischen doch
eine welt im umbruch
zahlreiche spuren hier zeugen von der
venezianischen handels tradition mit
partien
[Musik]
kamele pferde und schiffe haben schon
vor zwei jahrtausenden porzellan oder
seite hierher nach europa gebracht und
in der gegenrichtung sind begehrte
europäische produkte nach außen gelangt
aber auch philosophien und religionen
wurden die verschiedenen routen der
seidenstraße ausgetauscht
million stand einst das haus der
venezianischen händler familie polo
wissenschaftler streiten sich zwar um
marco polo viel erreicht hat
unbestritten aber resta venezianer der
einst hier hinter diesen mauern gelebt
hat er hat wohl wie kein anderer dazu
beigetragen dass die seidenstraße zum
inbegriff für den jahrhundertealten
handels und kulturaustausch zwischen
asien und europa geworden ist
riesige kreuzfahrtschiffe spucken
regelmäßig tausende tagestouristen an
dann die passagiere dieser monster
schiffe verstopfen die plätze und gassen
der lagunenstadt sie sind aber
gleichzeitig willkommene kunden
[Musik]
ich mache mich auf zu einem der
venezianer der sich bei real tor brücke
mit seiner sogenannten bank carrell
neben den chinesischen händlern immer
noch behaupten kann
[Musik]
venezianische halbmasken sind die
spezialität von alessandro masala masken
aus italienischer herstellung verkauft
aber auch preisgünstigere aus china dem
wirtschaftlichen druck aus fernost kann
eben auch alessandro nicht ganz
ausreichen
hier in venedig dreht sich alles ums
geld
leute die wenig älter sind als ich haben
alles verkauft es genügte ihm das geld
zu nehmen
die venezianische tradition ist ihnen
nicht wichtig die chinesen machen es
heute wie die italiener vor 50 jahren
als diese in die ganze welt reist und
weil es hier nichts gab
sie arbeiteten und legten das geld
beiseite so verläuft die entwicklung
weltweit
und wo bleiben dabei die stärken die
eigentlichen interessen der italiener
schöne frage heute wie es ist nirgends
auch die italiener haben inzwischen
fabriken in china
so bezahlen sie weniger und schaffen es
mit der chinesischen konkurrenz
mitzuhalten
die italienische stärke viel ist in
italien
der markusplatz so kennt man venedig von
den ansichtskarten seit ein paar jahren
übernehmen hier immer mehr chinesen
venezianische geschäfte bars oder
restaurants an einem der westlichen
endpunkte der seidenstraße werden also
nicht nur waren aus asien gehandelt hier
menschen mittlerweile immer mehr
menschen aus fernost selbst in der
geschäftswelt mit
die unternehmerin mit dem italienischen
übernahmen laura stammt aus venture
shanghai
ihre brüder und ihre schwester leben
ebenfalls hier tochter jessica und ihr
bruder sind in venedig geboren
denn jessica erwachsene ist möchte die
mutter habe mich dass sie einen
italiener heiratet einen italiener wie
es nach mir geht nein ich sage nicht die
italiener seien gut oder schlecht aber
ich bevorzuge unsere landsleute
es ist einfacher zusammen zu reden sich
kulturell zu verstehen mit einem
italiener braucht es mehr zeit meiner
meinung nach in der galerie fabry einer
seitengasse zum markusplatz besitzt
laura gleich drei geschäfte samt der
liegenschaften hier ihre pizzeria sie
wenn die arbeit ohne die besitzer
gemacht wird geht es nicht gut
klar auch die angestellten arbeiten
tüchtig aber es braucht immer ein
wachsames auge
der chef muss da sein sonst ändert sich
alles
sonst arbeiten die angestellten drei
tage in der woche und vier bleiben sie
zu hause
stimmt doch denn ich muss ja den lohn
bezahlen es ist ja nichts gratis
lauras jüngere schwester eva verkauft in
ein accessoire laden italienische
original produkte
das chinesische credo in der
geschäftswelt hier die ganze familie
arbeitet stets mit laura besucht hier
den luxus kinder kleiderladen der
jüngere bruder leon für die meisten
kunden fragen offenbar ob wirklich all
die teuren kinderartikel echt und
vielleicht gefälscht sind
besonders kritisch sind chinesische
kunden
sie sehen in china dass es dort
massenhaft fälschungen gibt dann kommen
sie hierher und wollen wissen sind die
echt oder gefälscht
in venedig trifft man auf viele
chinesische waren aber auch auf
chinesisches personal
ich reise weiter zuerst nach istanbul an
den bosporus europäische tor zu asien
hier tauche ich in eine orientalische
welt ein
europa und asien liegen an der engsten
stelle des bosporus nur 700 meter
voneinander entfernt im austausch
zwischen diesen beiden kontinenten ist
dann wohl das einstige konstantinopel
seit jeher eine wichtige stellung ein
[Musik]
es ist die besondere atmosphäre zwischen
orient und okzident welche mich in
istanbul in ihrem band sind im großen
basar der stadt wird seit jahrhunderten
geschäftet und gefeilscht
hier sind die geschichte des handels
verbrauch dessen veränderungen spürbar
ein antiquitätenhändler begleitet mich
ein stück weit durch den basar
ich erkläre ihm was mich persönlich
amerikanischen qualitätswein fasziniert
und dass es mich überrascht wie offen
der fälschungen von schweizer uhren zu
sehen
für allein ist darf den ersten blick
kaum erkennbar dass es sich um
fälschungen handelt ja klar die kommen
aus china meint der junge verkäufer die
kosten 150 euro das stück sei den uhren
zwar kaum anzusehen aber es sei doch
klar dass es fälschungen zeigen
[Musik]
ich verlasse das moderne istanbul und
begebe mich auf dem asiatischen
kontinent nach anatolien ins türkische
hinterland in einem wiederum ganz andere
welt
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit dem zug
[Applaus]
[Musik]
position
dass die türkei ein europäisches oder
ein asiatisches land ein asiatisches
allenfalls immer wieder wird darüber
gestritten ob die türkei zu europa
gehöre der wirtschaftlichen fakten
sprechen zwar dafür gesellschaftlich
wird der graben zwischen westlichen
werten und jenen die präsidenten waren
vertritt aber immer größer
[Musik]
die lag ja ja und ihre schwester
salihamidzic setzen schon seit stunden
mit mir im selben wagen zu meiner
überraschung sind sie es die das
gespräch den kontakt mit mir gesucht
haben und wir beschließen gemeinsam mit
unserer türkisch dolmetscherin den
speisewagen aufzusuchen
die leg ist mutter eines
schulpflichtigen tochter sie selbst
befasst sich in einem fernkurs mit
psychologie sie versteht sich als
muslimin welche selbstbewusst an ihrer
zukunft baut traditionellen etwas
moderner in den idee ich denke nicht in
schablonen niemals ich bin offen
frau sein heißt zuerst einmal mutter
sein selbstlos sein
selbstlos sein heißt etwas zu erreichen
indem man teilt dazu muss man arbeiten
arbeiten heißt ich brauche eine
ausbildung für eine ausbildungs man
kämpfen
man muss daran glauben und wenn man all
dies führt gibt es nichts das man nicht
schaffen kann
deshalb trägt sie das kopftuch das ist
für mich kein persönlichkeits vorbild
sondern meine meinung aus religiöser
sicht es macht mich stolz das kopftuch
zu tragen
es ist kein hindernis für mich meine
ziele zu erreichen es genügt etwas
erreichen zu wollen
der wieder zu
sie leben als frau in einer muslimischen
welt kämpfen dabei aber für gewisse
freiheiten natürlich alles hat seinen
platz absolut mein glaube ist meine
persönliche wahl nichts kann mich daran
hindern meinen glauben auszuüben
aber das heißt nicht dass ich meine
freiheit verlieren will
alles hat seine grenzen wenn es darauf
ankommt kann ich von meiner freiheit
opfern
und wenn es darauf ankommt opfere ich
finde meinen glauben
danke
es sind weniger die restriktiven
kleidervorschriften es ist offenbar mehr
die zugewiesene geschlechterrolle mit
der sich die leute ja immer wieder mal
schwer tut
[Musik]
wir nähern uns den bergen bei erzurum
die stadt und das tal hier liegen auf
1900 metern über meer
[Musik]
am nächsten tag kurz nach sonnenaufgang
besuche ich in der nähe von erzurum den
hof der familie tikici hier tauche ich
in die bäuerliche welt anatolien zeigen
die bauern im kleinen dorf treiben ihre
kühe zum dorfausgang und von dort auf
die weide zum frühstück treffe ich die
ganze familie tikici vater ludwig 83 und
sagt dass er bislang gar nicht gewusst
habe dass es menschen gibt die nicht
türkisch sprechen und solche die nicht
muslime sind ja sie in peking china sohn
von luke klagt darüber dass es den
türkischen kleinbauern hier zusehends
schlechter gehe
in den läden der stadt werde seit die
türkei den markt gegenüber europa
geöffnet habt vor allem importiert das
billigfleisch angeboten in der stadt
bieten die händler das fleisch viel
billiger an als mir alles importiert ist
und drücken bei uns die preise gestern
zum beispiel kauften sich iris kilo für
600 im stadtzentrum verkaufen sie es für
1500 hier aus dem dorf kommen so nur
schwer über die runden
wir kaufen teuer ein und die eigenen
produkte können wir nur billig verkaufen
jetzt erfahre ich dass der vater für den
sohn eine braut organisiert hat nach der
heirat von die künftige ehefrau hier auf
dem hof und im haushalt helfen ob das
denn gut kommt zu meiner zukunft kann
ich so viel sei so wie ich lebe so wird
auch die person die mich heiratet leben
müssen
ich kann hier nicht mehr anbieten als
ich habe ich habe keine erwartungen vom
leben wie du lebst du wirst du deshalb
gibt es keine probleme
und weil wir nun schon fast ein bisschen
freunde geworden sind nehmen mich die
breiten aus dem
kleinen dorf orte mit nach erzurum
[Applaus]
ja sind tikici lädt mich zum besuch
einer ahs anmutenden pferdesport
veranstaltung einst ein schaf polo fast
überall entlang der asiatischen
seitenstraße sind immer wieder solche
wettkämpfe zu sehen
zwei mannschaften versuchen sich
gegenseitig ein schafsfell abzujagen
und dieses fällen möglichst oft ins
eigene tor ins eigene lager zu bringen
[Musik]
von erzurum haben wir nun weiter nach
batumi die georgische hafenstadt am
schwarzen meer
der hafen von batumi ist in den letzten
jahren stark gewachsen
darauf ist betriebsleiter peggys rasch
an ic stolz
juni zur sagte er werde immer wichtiger
im netz der großen der modernen
seidenstraße
ich liebe meine arbeit weil wir hier an
einem der wichtigsten orte wirken die es
in unserer geschichte je gegeben hat
der hafen von batumi gehört zu den
weltweit ältesten in der geschichte den
gibt es bereits seit dem zweiten
jahrhundert nach christus die
weiterentwicklung georgiens aber auch
die geschicke in unseren nachbarländern
armenien und aserbaidschan hänge nicht
zuletzt von diesem mehr anschluss ab und
wir sind daran die umschlags
möglichkeiten hier dauernd zu verbessern
[Musik]
die meiste ware kommt aus dem westen
geld in georgien ist vorhanden vor allem
weil das land stark vom geldsegen
westlicher entwicklungsorganisationen
profitiert
[Musik]
die georgische hafenstadt batumi hat
eine bewegte geschichte
sie ist einst von griechen gegründet
worden war unter anderem mal und dort
politische kontrolle
zuletzt gehörte sie zur sowjetunion
[Musik]
in den letzten jahren ist batumi rigoros
ausgebaut worden vor allem reiche türken
werden in die neuen casino von
fünf-sterne-hotels von batumi gelockt
auf mich wirkt die stadt wie ein
top-ten- pinsdorf wie eine kulisse
welche die wirkliche situation der stadt
und des landes kaschiert wenn man sich
auch nur ein paar hundert meter aus dem
stadtzentrum hinaus bewegt in die
wohnviertel zu machen die sie einen
armseligen eindruck hat die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist arbeitslos viele
menschen scheinen zu resignieren
[Musik]
ich verlasse die stadt am schwarzen meer
und fahre um die bergwelt der
georgischen region abchasien
von batumi trifft ein stück weit hoch
richtung bärtschi pass
hier bilden bergtal treffe ich auf ein
ganz anderes georgi die menschen die von
einer bescheidenen landwirtschaft leben
wirken besonders selbstbewusst
alle hotels hier am werk seien
ausgebucht ich würde aber trotzdem eine
unterkunft finden hat man mehr
versprochen
im bergdorf kola noch vor der passhöhe
betreiber nämlich der polizeichef mit
der vermietung von gästebetten anliegen
geschäft
ob ich hier bereit sind hugo bin ja
richtig ich soll mich auf dem
polizeiposten melden
und schon kommt mir in zivilkleidung
jumbo backwards entgegen er wirklich zu
seinem hause nehme ich für eine nacht
mein bett beziehen werde
das haus hat er zum teil selbst gebaut
die betten stehen bereit aber sehr viele
leute schauen hier wohl nicht vorbei ich
bin nicht der polizeichef hier mord
sondern ermittler
meine frau ist kinderärztin und das ist
unser heim
sie beherbergen immer wieder gäste nicht
immer aber abrutschen
manchmal meldet sich jemand sucht nach
einem dach überm kopf
mir gefällts in kulow
und am nächsten morgen ist es schon hell
werbe ich von jumbo und seiner frau zum
frühstück eingeladen
beide sind geschäftstüchtig verbrauch
sehr liebenswürdig klatsch ab juli heißt
dieser typisch georgische käsekuchen
schakuri sind ziemlich über kreuz ist
hier aufgewachsen er fühlt sich einst
mit dem dorf und dagegen tier mit seinem
optimismus auch schwierige zeiten gut
überstanden
er hätte vermeint er auch alles
hinschmeißen und in einer stadt ziehen
können
plötzlich greift mit sicherem griff
neben seinen sessel ein cognac nach
meinem rezept lasst uns ihn probieren
mit 45 prozent ist ein nicht sehr
hochprozentig
lasst uns trinken auf deinen besuch auf
ein langes leben hier bei uns in dieser
luft lebt man lange war ich wohl auch
also auf die gäste wer wollte dieser
gastfreundschaft wieder stehen jetzt in
diesem moment weiß ich noch nicht dass
dies nicht das letzte schnapsglas ist da
sich an diesem vormittag in meinen
händen halten werden
bis zur passhöhe auf 2025 metern ist es
noch ziemlich weit um die straße wird
immer schlechter
zu zeiten der sowjetunion war diese
gegend sperrgebiet sie bildete einst die
südliche außengrenze des warschauer
paktes zum nato land türkei
[Musik]
treffpunkt für die härten für die
straßenarbeiter und fertig
durchreisenden ist hier auf der passhöhe
dieser kleine kiosk innert kürze bin ich
hier mitten in einem buch prozentigen
trinkgelage bisher erhält mehr diese
härte kaum je ein ausländer hier
vorbeigekommen deshalb müsse unsere
einkehr jetzt gefeiert werden
ehrensache
nach einer üppigen talfahrt 30 weiter
über die stadt bocholt ihren
mineralwasserquellen bis nach gori der
geburtsstadt stalins stalin hat der
einst mit seiner nationalitätenpolitik
die basis für die jüngsten bürger kriege
auf dem gebiet der ehemaligen
sowjetunion gelegt
mit einem team des internationalen
komitees vom roten kreuz besuche ich
eine note siedlung die das ikk etwas
außerhalb von gori für besonders
bedürftige vertriebene aus südossetien
eingerichtet hat im sommer 2008 hatte
georgien seinen krieg gegen die
separatistischen osten verloren
jetzt ist sie doch see ziehen vom
übrigen georgien doch grenzsperren
getrennt und georgien damals vertrieben
worden sind sie können nicht mehr in
ihre heimat zurück
über 10.000 solche unterkünfte auch für
die vertriebenen aus asien haben die
hilfswerke im ganzen ort in gebaut
ebenerdige einfach ausgestattete häuser
[Musik]
in ca jobs zu bestätigen sie hat mit
ihrem mann einen ethnischen georgier in
südossetien einen hof betrieben
kriegsausbruch 2008 ist ihr flucht
gelungen
von ihrem mann aber fehlt jede spur bei
ethnischen säuberungen ist er
wahrscheinlich getötet worden
die rentnerin ist froh dass sie hier
wenigstens ein dach über dem kopf hat
nein das ist nicht mein eigentliches
zuhause
ich vermisse unser stück erde
meine leute wer gern wieder dort hamburg
viele heimatlose viele vertriebene sind
auf hilfe angewiesen
das allerschlimmste sei sie keine
nachricht über den verbleib ihres mannes
zu haben
was geschehen ist ist geschehen
das war wohl schicksal musste wohl so
kommen
ich singe auf keine rache niemand es ist
wichtig zu vergeben
sie ist zwar eines videos trotzdem
können sie nicht in ihr dorf nach süd
ossetien zurück sie würde dort verfolgt
weil sie mit einem ethnischen georgier
verheiratet war sagt sie
und sie teilt dieses schicksal mit
vielen anderen auch mehr als acht jahre
nach dem kriegsende
[Musik]
von gori fahrig weiter in die georgische
hauptstadt blies
[Musik]
die stadt wehrt ähnlich wie batumi
modernisiert die cura auf georgisch und
klar ist der größte fluss im kaukasus
[Musik]
es sind vor allem die alten häuser mit
den balkonen und weintrauben die
verträumten plätze in der altstadt
welche ließ sie seinen besonderen juwel
machen
[Musik]
immer wenn ich ihn besuche ich lascher
bakradse ein geistreicher mensch der im
literaturmuseum unter anderem die
bibliophilen schätze des landes
verwaltet und seine museum findet man
dokumente welche wertvollen aufschluss
über das leben längs der nördlichen
zeithstraße geben aber 19 jahrhundert
ist diese bibel abgeschrieben im
zwölften jahrhundert auch berg athos in
gechingen dass die orthodoxie unheimlich
wichtige ort ist in welchen sprach linie
ist natürlich dass ich so evangeliar und
das ist das einzelstück gibt es
inzwischen keine rein zu stellen das ist
ein handgeschriebenes also schau mal wie
klein schläft ja auch das fast eine lupe
braucht man kein lob hat man gute augen
damals gesagt du kannst das lesen ich
kenne das ja auch lesen und das schöne
glaube das ist wie gestern geschrieben
nicht alles ist so gut erhalten wie das
gibt natürlich evangelisten bilder drin
die bilder sind aus schiff zu entern 100
meter breite vorbeigeführt
es war sehr oft so damals in dieser zeit
aber das gericht jetzt wunderbar sascha
ist auch ein georgischer patriot oft
kommt in ihm wut hoch gegen das einstige
sowjet regime und gegen dessen haupt er
und die russen
woher kommt eine wut geld ist klein und
gegenüber anja wassertheurer auch mit
geprägt es war die mondlandung szene die
mir wirklich eingeprägt ist im kopf und
die mondlandung szene war in der
sowjetischen fernsehen wurde gezeigt
vielleicht paar sekunden lang als ob es
nichts besonderes wäre und ich kann sehr
gut erinnern mein vater und ein freund
von ihm sagst im folgenden fenster und
haben so berg jetzt haben wir dann
wissen wir ja und wenn man in so eine
situation aufwächst
die ist natürlich sehr distanzierte
haltung zu russland und es ist
vielleicht für viele georgier und viele
postsowjetische länder
nicht sehr typisch aber für mich war das
immer klar dass diese so wird oder und
zugrunde geht
und ich war sehr froh dass es zugrunde
gegangen ist es gibt nicht mal ein
bisschen nostalgie und sie sondern auch
wirklich lernen eines wunderschönen
tagesumsatz gleichberechtigt nachbarn zu
akzeptieren dann werden wir freunde
werden hoppla scharf wunsch in moskau
erhört werden wert ich weiß es nicht und
fahre weiter von der georgischen
hauptstadt wie sie immer ostwärts
doch paket dem oder sagenumwobene
georgische wein wächst an der idyllisch
gelegene bergstadt sich nagy vorbei bis
zur grenze nach aserbaidschan
von venedig bin ich über istanbul dann
quer durch die türkei durch die
kaukasusrepublik georgien bis nach jacky
in aserbaidschan gereist
[Musik]
diese afghanische staat ihren
orientalischen charme bewahrt
entlang der außenmauer der
karawansereien wert kunsthandwerk
angeboten
die stadt schießt ein wichtiges
touristen ziel
[Musik]
außerhalb des stadtzentrums sind auch
hier die altlasten der untergegangenen
sowjetunion deutlich sichtbar
verlotterter industriegebäude zeitzeugen
der einstigen sozialistischen
planwirtschaft und überall im land ihre
porträts die alijews der staatspräsident
und sein verstorbener vater
[Musik]
die wohl attraktivste sehenswürdigkeiten
gps der wunderschöne hahn palast
das unesco kulturerbes ist in den
letzten jahren vom deutschen
spezialisten sorgfältig restauriert
worden
[Musik]
im obergeschoss des palast sind besuchs
zimmer die darstellung heldenhafter
kampfszenen der armee des krans wände
und decken im ganzen gebäude sind
zentimeter und zentimetern mit äußerst
reicher bund und teils auch mit naiver
malerei aus dem späten 18ten jahrhundert
geschmückt
[Musik]
ich fahre weiter richtung osten von
ferne grüßen die gipfel des großen
kaukasus
dem duft des frischen fladenbrot es mag
ich nicht widerstehen
es sind vertriebene aus nagorny karabach
deren kinder und enkel die hier unter
einfachsten verhältnissen leben leben
sie von mama ruth verkauf mehr schlecht
als recht
diese slums schmeckt wunderbar wir
frauen hier button alle brot unsere
männer wüten die schafe und ziegen oder
arbeiten auf dem feld haben sie kinder
ja wir sind zu viert ich bin verheiratet
und habe eine tochter und einen sohn
das schicksal der rund 500.000 karabach
vertriebenen in aserbaidschan macht
betroffen sie sind ein spielball der
politik wirklich helfen will ihnen
niemand
brotverkauf beschert den vertriebenen
ihren kindern und enkeln bloß einen
kleinen zustupf
die aserbaidschanische hauptstadt baku
erreiche ich erst als es bereits dunkel
ist
die drei flammen türme machen deutlich
dass hier vor allem öl und gas den
reichtum bestimmen
jedenfalls den reichtum jener die das
schicksal des landes lenken und
persönlich vom rohstoffgeschäft
profitieren
hier die halle die eigens für den
eurovision song contest richtet wurde
[Musik]
ganze wohnviertel mussten damals
modernen bürogebäuden weichen die
einstigen altstadtbewohner von baku sind
zum teil rücksichtslos ausquartiert wort
nichts gar nichts darf der von präsident
ali regierte modernisierung der stadt im
wege stehen
ich verlasse baku der halbstaatliche
energiekonzern sogar öffnet uns sein
reich wir fliegen die einst geheim
gehaltene erdl starb läuft da schlagen
diese liegt rund 50 kilometer vom ufer
entfernt im kaspischen meer
klar ist die älteste und war bis vor
kurzem die größte ölförderanlage der
welt auf offener see so erdbürger
bezeichneten sie einst als industrielles
weltwunder
dieses netzwerk mit über 300 km
verbindung stehen plattformen unter
kleinen arbeiter stand
[Musik]
von hier aus wird das gewonnene öl gas
pipelines aufs festland gepumpt und von
dort nach südosteuropa
auf der künstlichen insel arbeiten stets
über 2000 menschen vor allem männer in
zwei wochen schicht betrieb rund um die
uhr
die löhne auf der insel sind zwei bis
dreimal höher als jene der meisten
anderen arbeitsstellen auf dem
afrikanischen festland
alkohol ist hier strikte verboten wäre
auch nur mit einer flasche bier erwischt
wird verliert auf der stelle seinen job
wir fahren ins zentrum der plattform die
stadt auf stelzen abwechselnd etwa 2000
menschen wohnen und wo auch die labors
untergebracht sind
hier arbeitet seit 16 jahren die
chemikerin rachinger acht meter war
zusammen mit ihrer kollegin analysiert
sie erdulden
gemessen wird der wasseranteil im rohöl
und anhand der proben wird dann
entschieden in welchen sedimentschichten
weiter gebohrt werden soll
meine arbeit habe ich keine probleme
aber die lebenssituation ist schwierig
rundherum hat man ständig nur dass mir
man kann nirgendwo hin nach der arbeit
gehst du in den sport zahlen ein wenig
spazieren dann kommst du nach hause und
schaust ein bisschen fern und weg sich
schlafen und am morgen musst du wieder
früh zur arbeit
es ist eintönig 78 tage hintereinander
ein und dasselbe
in früheren zeiten war es luftiger sagt
achimer damals sei hier noch kräftig
gefeiert und getrunken worden
neuerdings dem kaspischen meer immer
mehr gas gefördert aus einer tiefe von
bis zu 3000 metern
die firma sogar oft so riesige
gasvorkommen erschließen zu können
herr lieferungen vor allem nach
westeuropa zurück in der hauptstadt baku
die sich gerne westlich und offen gibt
doch nichts täuscht darüber hinweg dass
klaren des präsidenten kontrolle das
land rücksichtslos freie wahlen freie
medien gibt es in aserbaidschan nicht
schlecht steht es auch und die
menschenrechte präsident alijew wert in
der staatlichen inszenierung wie einem
göttlichen heilsbringer gehuldigt
trotzdem ganz unterdrücken lassen sich
die kritischen stimmen nicht in baku
gibt es eine mutige blogger-szene
parkanlage treffe ich sauer kenan ali
und ebenen
ein bisschen mulmig ist mir zwar zumute
doch die blogger sind bereit sich bei
ihrem namen nennen und auch filmen zu
lassen
es sei ihnen wichtig ein zeichen für
offenheit zu setzen
als junger mensch müsse man seine wahl
treffen zu gunsten des autokratischen
präsidenten regimes oder eben zu gunsten
einer ersehnten freien demokratie
wir wissen nicht wo die rote linie ist
die wir nicht überschreiten dürfen
manchmal kannst du sehr kritische dinge
sagen ohne bestrafung manchmal sagst du
etwas weniger kritisch und west sofort
verhaftet denken sie dass das internet
in ihrem land politische veränderungen
anstoßen
es gibt leute die sich eine veränderung
wünschen und ich bin teil dieser gruppe
und wenn es leute gibt die so denken und
sich für einen wandel einsetzen ist ein
wandel unvermeidbar das inspiriert und
lässt hoffen
von einem arabischen frühling ist in
aserbaidschan allerdings kaum die rede
zu straff hält das regime aliev halten
seine engsten verbündeten die zügel des
landes in der hand
aserbaidschan ist voller widersprüche es
ist nicht ganz einfach dieselben
nachzuvollziehen
[Musik]
von venedig aus über die türkei georgien
und aserbaidschan bin ich nun im westen
kasachstans angelangt
die stadt akte hieß einst schewtschenko
der chef wollte hier seine
technokratischen machbarkeits visionen
umsetzen und beweisen dass man ganze
wüsten zu blühenden gärten verwandeln
könne
doch sein projekt mißlang heute bündelt
sich in acta in straßen und schienen zu
einem der wichtigsten
verkehrsknotenpunkte kasachstans
von hier aus gelangen zum teil an
russland vorbei öl gas aber auch
verschiedene waren aus china direkt nach
westeuropa
[Musik]
es kam ein fahrer hat die hauptstraße
verlassen und fährt hier als ob er sich
auf einer abfahrtpiste befinden würde
weite steppen und wüsten prägen hier das
land
naja
etwa ein dutzend leute leben in der
siedlung botschafter von der kamel
haltung und der kamel aufzucht noch
herrscht ruhe im gehege die kamele
scheinen den tagesablauf zu können
zuerst kommt das kleine dran und erst
danach die milch kessel gefüllt
[Musik]
kamelmilch gilt das besonders gesund sie
enthält mehr wolken proteine und etwa
dreimal so viel vitamin c wie kuhmilch
zudem viel eisen und vitamin b kam bewag
muss aber war er lange die einzige frau
weit und breit sie hat die kamelfarm
lange alleine geführt und den betrieb
erst vor vier jahren ihr mich an
reporter übergeben
die kamele stehen in einer engen
beziehung zu den menschen die kamele zu
züchten ist ganz einfach
es hängt alles nur davon wie du mit dem
tier umgehst dementsprechend verhält
sich das kamel dir gegenüber für die
zucht bringen wir den kamelen sei dass
sie im gehege bleiben müssen
jedes hat seinen namen und es reagiert
auch wenn es gerufen wird auf mich
wirken diese tiere etwas fremd zum teil
auch unheimlich obwohl sie sich
überhaupt nicht aggressiv verhalten
[Musik]
im verlauf des vormittags werden die
ausgewachsenen kamel für in die steppe
freigelassen
ihr elastische und gemächlicher gang
zieht mich in bann und lässt so beim
betrachten auch in mir selbst eine
gewisse gelassenheit aufkommen
doch es sind nicht nur chamäleon kamel
züchtung für heute das zentralasiatische
land kennzeichnen die ehemalige
kasachische hauptstadt almaty hat
ausgedient astana ist jetzt die neue
kasachische hauptstadt derzeit präsident
des landes hat sich hier ein denkmal
setzen lassen
geld spielt keine rolle gross soll alles
sein einzigartig ein denkmal für die
ewigkeit
[Musik]
und er ist einer von jenen rächen die
stadt geplant und gebaut haben
mohammad eibl kopf
noch vor 18 jahren hieß dieser ort
abholen
zu deutsch weißes grad und es gab hier
mehr oder weniger gar nichts doch dann
kam der präsident mit seinem architekten
[Musik]
zentralasiatische personenkult oben in
beit rektoren die haben den den
vergoldeten handabdruck des
staatspräsidenten zu legen das bringe
glück sagt der volksmund kritische
stimmen gibt es kaum
krems
was soll ich sagen weil sie hingehört
unser land
und unsere zukunft nur soll dann nach
der brief ist seit 26 jahren
autokratischer bauernpräsident bislang
liegt es ihm gelungen nachhaltige
proteste gegen sein regime zurück zu
trennen
sein architekt schwärmt von der
kasachische präsident ist ein mensch der
weiterdenkt als alle anderen
ich habe noch nie jemanden getroffen der
so tiefsinnig und weise ist wie er und
der trotz all dieser unglaublichen
qualitäten gleichzeitig wie soll ich
sagen ein so bescheidener mensch
geblieben ist
die astana uss cole entworfene von
johanna take off
geld aus der staatskasse reichtum der
präsidentenfamilie und je nur gewisser
geschäftsleute sind wichtig für
baumeister matthey buff wo genau am ende
das geld herkommt weiß ich nicht wichtig
ist einfach dass genügend davon da ist
alles kostet geld das land die
projektentwicklung die kommunikation das
bauen ohne geld läuft nichts
im schatten der prachtbauten das andere
astana hier leben jene die nichts vom
reichtum abbekommen haben in ihren
häusern gibt es kein fließendes wasser
und keine toiletten
ich möchte dass wir auch in richtigen
häusern wohnen können nicht so wie hier
mit fließendem wasser so zumindest meine
kinder und enkelkinder sollten das
erleben dürfen
die neue tschechische hauptstadt astana
soll in die geschichte eingehen auch mit
export 2017 die sich energietechnologie
themen an dem wird
[Musik]
nach dem ausflug nach astana geht meine
reise weiter der bahn von hafenstadt
akko nachbarn
[Musik]
nur ab und zu sehe ich in der steppe
kanäle und am horizont kleine hügel
tektonischen verwerfungen
sonst aber ist es hier wie fast überall
in kasachstan flach so weit das auge
reicht kaum je sind menschen zu sehen
kaum je ein haus
betrieb herrscht dafür im zug es sind
vor allem familien in dem zug reisen und
weil die fahrten lange dauern bilden
sich hier oft spontane
schicksalsgemeinschaft
man spielt man ist und man freut sich
zusammen
[Musik]
im benachbarten waggon sind die
platzverhältnisse noch etwas enger
die luft ist stickig die stimmung aber
ist gut ich solle mich doch hinsetzen ja
im vergleich zur schweizer das leben für
sie in kasachstan wohl etwas anfälliger
meint der familienvater ein arbeiter in
der ölindustrie
wir hätten eigentlich alles auch eine
gut ausgebildete jugend aber es fehlt an
arbeit verlassen deshalb viele junge das
land nein wo sollen die denn hin
die meisten jungen bei uns halten es
hier aus denn ihr ehemann ärgers sind
seine frau widerspricht ich versuche die
situation durch ein ablenkungsmanöver zu
retten und wende mich der tochter zu was
willst du mal werden
lehrerin
die
die mutter will wissen ob man sowas auch
in der schweiz ist das ist kodak
gebratenes fleisch und ja das schmeckt
[Musik]
die landschaft kasachstans trainer waren
andere große wüstenlandschaften der welt
doch ich bin hier nicht im wilden westen
sondern gewissermaßen im wilden osten
[Musik]
von beinahe fahre ich auf einer
schlechten straße ostwärts zum
grenzübergang nach usbekistan einem land
das sehr viel autoritär regiert wird als
kasachstan sattelschlepper aus der
ukraine aus polen aus russland und
deutschland sie transportieren maschinen
oder nahrungsmittel in den osten und
kleidung oder teppiche in den westen
ein sattelschlepper mit ausgebrannter
führerkabine
guten tag das ist denn hier passiert
das kam ja
waren sie der fahrer ja ich bin der
fahrer ich war gerade draußen als zu
brennen begann
ich habe ein wasser geholt und andere
fahrer haben in einer löschen geholfen
er klar ich habe nur einen kleinen
feuerlöscher dem war hier nichts
auszurichten
der frachtraum ist er jetzt leer
nein ich habe deutsche butter geladen
und die ist unbeschädigt das
kühlaggregat läuft noch die temperatur
drin ist in ordnung und das fahrzeug
selbst ist des versichert ja in der
ukraine
ich wünsche dem paar alles gute
wie viele tage er noch unter der
glühenden sonne auf ein ersatzfahrzeug
warten muss er weiß es nicht
wir waren nur eine verhältnismäßig kurze
strecke in größten dem städten reichsten
zentralasiatischen land kasachstan
unterwegs denn unsere nördliche
seidenstraßen route führt und nun zu
tiefen grenzübergang und danach quer
durch usbekistan
venedig die türkei den südkaukasus und
west kasachstan lasse ich nun hinter mir
zurück
an diesem langen abschnitt der
usbekischen fernverkehrsstraße wert seit
jahren gewerkelt kilometer weit nur
provisorien und baustellen auf diesem
streckenabschnitt wird die seidenstraße
zu erleiden straße die sich endlich das
sagenumwobene bugrad erreiche
zusammen mit seiner band gehört statt
wucherer zu den wichtigsten usbekischen
städten die mit wunderschön
restaurierten moscheen mit minaretten
und mit riesen aufwarten
problematischere sollen ausländer nicht
zu sehen bekommen die usbekischen
behörden bemühen sich deshalb uns mit
klar vorgegebenen kulturprogramm an
einer kurzen und kontrollierbaren leine
zu halten
besuche das appelliert er hat hat zur
familie von abdullah abdullah der
traditionelle familien und
vorzeigebetrieb ist auch in der
sowjetischen zeit nicht verstaatlicht
worden und wird nun wegen des tourismus
von dem usbekischen behörden unterstützt
die tonerde stamme aus der region
auch die farben würden direkt der natur
ab gewonnen und die muster und motive
sie seien von generation zu generation
weitergereicht worden
unsere ton schalen durchlaufen einen
umfangreichen prozess die erste klausur
die zweite zweimal werden die schalen
gebrannt und hier kommt dann noch eine
letzte kleine nicht unwichtige etappe
der verkauf das ist ein kleiner scherz
aber ohne geschäft kam alles zum
stillstand
von bucherer aus reisig weiter ostwärts
nach sommer kommt
auf dem registan platz ziemlich die wohl
berühmtesten fassaden usbekischer
koranschule in ihren bahnen
von einem muslimischen fundamentalisten
ossa ist auch hier kam was zu stören
die über 30 millionen usbekin usbeken
leben einen auffallend moderaten
säkulären islam
gerne werden wir noch ein wenig ihr
gebieten doch unsere reiseplan ist mit
den usbekischen behörden abgesprochen
unsere reiseleiterin wird dabei selbst
von den behörden überwachten die sollen
in usbekistan nur das zu sehen bekommen
was dem rechen genehm ist möglichst
nichts wagemut von der korruption oder
von der repression im land
[Musik]
drinnen im zug fährt unsere
reiseleiterin nervös
ich bleibe die meiste zeit auf meinem
reservierten platz setzen weil sich dann
mal versuche auf einen band und sessel
zu wechseln
taucht sofort ein bewacher auf und
erkundigt sich nach meinem vor bleibt
fazit wir werden strenger überwacht als
ihr bislang vermutet hatten
die 350 kilometer in die hauptstadt
taschkent legen wir den
hochgeschwindigkeitszug aproz iab im nu
zurück im usbekischen präsidenten palast
wert autoritär regiert auch unter dem
neuen staatspräsidenten schafft carmio
es darauf dass sich das land kaum öffnen
kaum demokratischer und wohl auch kaum
weniger korrupt werden
während es viele neigen wohnung in der
hauptstadt an wasser fehlt sprudelt es
hier demonstrativ vor den gebäuden der
macht
wir sind zwar mit vielen bewilligungen
ausgerüstet doch alle 50 meter steht ein
polizist der sich nicht vorwerfen lassen
will
er habe uns nicht ausreichend
kontrolliert
[Musik]
fast alles in usbekistan wird überwacht
um die politischen rechte im land ist es
schlecht bestellt das ist bekam die
stadt deshalb einem der wenigen
kritischen journalisten in taschkent
einen diskreten besuch ab wie erlebt er
sein land alexej iwanowitsch wurden den
anna etwas heruntergekommenen wohnung
und arbeitet von hier aus für
verschiedene internet agenturen
wir haben probleme mit den
menschenrechten aber auch mit dem recht
auf eigentum
ein beispiel sie eröffnen ein geschäft
investieren 30.000 dollar
und das geschäft läuft gut von morgen
können mitarbeiter der staatsführung
vorbei kommen und sagen fertig hier wird
eine tankstelle gebaut
es ist ein völlig nutzlos zu diskutieren
zur verstärkung kommt die polizei und
wer sich der staatsmacht entgegen stellt
ihn wird ein strafverfahren eröffnet
mit solchen methoden sind in den letzten
jahren tausende geschäfte geschlossen
worden
keiner der geschäftsleute hat je eine
kompensation erhalten
heute werden einfach enteignet alexej
will sich nicht entmutigen lassen
erläutert wie arm fiel ins becken durchs
leben kommen müssen in einem bereich
aber habe der kürzlich verstorbene
langjährige ex präsident karimow auf
sinnvolles getan
er ließ sie in den letzten jahren nicht
zu dass sich aus pakistan in ein zweites
afghanistan verwandelt er schränkte der
islamisten stark ein
derweil zweites afghanistan abzielten in
den 90er jahren wurden hier mit
unterstützung aus saudi arabien pakistan
und anderer länder islamistische werte
geweckt karimov gebot dem einhalt das
zweite positive was man zu karimov
erwähnen kann
er war kein wilder nationalist ähnliche
schwerpunkte wertvollen karimov
nachfolger der cdu absetzen
vom autoritär regierten kulturell aber
äußerst spannenden usbekistan führt mich
nun unsere reisen die kleine
zentralasiatische republik kirgistan
hier ist vieles etwas anders auch sehr
viel demokratischer bischkek die
hauptstadt die symbolik da macht der
rentier noch an die sowjetische
vergangenheit 2010 wurde das letzte
autoritäre regime des landes gestürmt
kirgistan hat sich danach bei einigen
turbulenzen einer parlamentarischen
demokratie zugewandt
auf diesen moment habe ich mich lange
gefragt ich bin unterwegs zur heldin des
kampfes um mehr demokratie in kirgistan
zur damaligen übergangspräsidentin rosa
otunbajewa
[Musik]
sie fühle sich heute leider unwohl werde
sich deshalb nur kurz zeit für uns
nehmen können hieß es zuerst an der
pforte erklärt mir weshalb die von ihr
angestoßenen reformen bei den kehrbesen
sofort anklang gefunden hätten
wir sind vom nomadentum geprägt und
haben ein ausgeprägtes
gerechtigkeitsgefühl lieber verlassen
wir unser dorf wenn wir dort nicht zu
unserer meinung stehen kann
dieser sinn für gerechtigkeit trägt dazu
bei dass unser volk eines autoritären
druck aushält
die kirgisen dulden es nicht wenn das
allgemeingut nur einer familie eines und
alle möchten dass die lebensbedingungen
in unserem schönen land immer besser
werden ihre nachbarländer usbekistan
kasachstan brauchtums tarnow trasse
bayern werden sehr autoritäre kia denken
sie dass es dort seinen arabischen
frühling kommen könnte
all unsere nachbarn ergreifende momente
maßnahmen mit denen die sogenannte
stabilität gestärkt werden soll
das internet wird kontrolliert mit neuen
gesetzen werden die einnahmen von
wohltätigen organisationen und parteien
kontrolliert
in meinen augen ist es falsch
man sollte den bürgern viel mehr schritt
um schritt mehr freiheiten gewähren
damit diese wirklich ihre eigene meinung
zum ausdruck bringen kann
die ehemalige übergangspräsidentin
unterbricht das gespräch sie will kurz
raus an die frische luft
bei der bevölkerung liest sie seit jeher
ein hohes ansehen
sie wirkte unter anderem als professorin
als botschafterin und als
außenministerin
sie hat ihr versprechen auch wirklich
gehalten und ist nach ablauf der
vereinbarten übergangszeit als
interimistische staatspräsidentin
abgetreten
für viele ist sie ein wichtiges symbol
die starke frau in der vor allem von
männern dominierten welt zentralasiens
möchten sie als frau die an vorderster
stelle in der politik gekämpft hat
beispiel sein für andere
zentralasiatische länder unbedingt
wir müssen uns von den vorurteilen
verabschieden
unsere wichtigste staatsanwälte zum
beispiel ist eine sehr schöne schlanke
junge frau
dabei hatten alle erwartet als als
staatsanwalt ein dicker bei harter kerl
gewählt werden müssen
nein das muss nicht sein unsere neue
staatsanwältin kennt alle gesetze sie
führt ihre arbeit äußerst professionell
durch man muss sich so endlich von den
althergebrachten vorurteilen
verabschieden
ich bedanke mich will mich verabschieden
verliert überraschend lädt mich rosa
otunbajewa nun nach dem offiziellen
interview termin doch zu sich nach hause
ein
zu einem brand in der küche gibt die
einstige credit sicher
übergangspräsidentin zu erkennen wie
wichtig hier neben der politik familie
meine mutter hat sieben töchter und
einen sohn zur welt gebracht und sie
selbst haben sie auch kinder ja zwei
einen sohn und eine tochter
und ich habe auch einen enkel er ist
super ja so süß den warmherzigen besuch
bei rosa otunbajewa werde ich wohl nie
vergessen
ich spreche auf die berge kirgistans
fischtheken comscore und dann richtung
song könnte
[Musik]
80 prozent des landes ist gebirgig bei
schönem wetter sind die ganzjährig
beschneiden gipfel zu sehen
[Musik]
hier starten wir zu einem dreitägigen
pferde tracking seit tagen hatten wir
uns auf diesen teil der reise gefreut
es ist vor allem ein projekt der
entwicklungsorganisation helvetas zu
verdanken dass die chinesischen bergbau
über diese tracks zu einer engen
zusammenarbeit untereinander finden und
mit den führungen und der per bergung
von touristen zu einem wichtigen
zusatzverdienst kommen
[Musik]
acht stunden sind wir nun vom ersten
tracking tag hoch zu ross unterwegs und
unsere york der auf der alb die lämpchen
erreichen wir erst als es längst dunkel
geworden ist
[Musik]
tagesanbruch auf knapp 3000 metern höhe
jetzt lernen wir unsere freundliche
gastgeber familie beck bei tageslicht
kennen
[Musik]
hier gibt es keine straße kein auto kein
wasser und keine elektrizität
der alltag konzentriert sich auf die
tiere und die natur elf personen leben
in dieser einfach eingerichteten jurte
welcher gleichzeitig als schlaf- wohn-
und essraum dient die zweite york ist
für die gäste bestimmt macht der kleine
aquila sie ist fasziniert
die haben viele gäste aus europa und wir
sagen ihnen bitte respektiert unsere
kultur unsere tradition die natur die
wir erhalten nicht
dieser rat gilt auch für die jungen
kirgisen in der stadt
die haben alles was sie wollen und
vergessen ihre eigene kultur und
tradition
[Musik]
allerdings der wunsch nach freier natur
ist nicht ganz ohne widerspruch gerne
nämlich der channel auch elektrisches
licht einen fernseher und mehr
radioprogramme immerhin ein freiluft
telefon gibt es hier schon
[Musik]
das zeigt mir wo seine orten jeweils
stehen wenn im frühjahr oben auf die
lämmchen noch schnee liegt
[Musik]
panama belgian racing in rudow ich liebe
meine art zu leben
es ist ein freies land
ich kann den platz meiner york tabellen
niemand in mir weg ich kann tun und
lassen was ich will
die art wie hier weitgehend autonom
gelebt wird und auch die geruhsame
stimmung sind beeindruckend der abschied
fällt uns schwer
trotzdem gehen müssen weiter über den
3400 meter hohen caracas
von weitem sehen wir den song chol
sedimentären kirgisischen gebirgssee auf
3000 metern höhe
er ist etwa halb so groß wie der
bodensee
[Musik]
auf der fahrt zur grenze nach china
treffen zwei verschiedene welten
aufeinander die moderne die sich kaum
mehr zurück halten lässt und jene der
credit sich mit nomaden traditionen von
kirgistan herführt annette routen der
örtlichen zeiten straße direkt in die
chinesische stadt kashgar hier in
kaschgar es der zusammenprall
verschiedener kulturen besonders
augenfällig die einfachen lehmhäusern
werden von uiguren bewohnt die modernen
wohn und geschäftshaus von den
zugewanderten han chinesen
die 2000 jahre alte altstadt wird von
der torque sprachigen volksgruppe der
uiguren bewohnt
viele der traditionellen leben und
backsteinhäuser aber so das credo der
regierung in peking müssen wurde bauten
weichen
die uiguren ihrerseits versuchen ihre
alpha weitgehend zu renovieren
erdbebensicher zu machen
sie möchten an ihrer muslimisch
geprägten lebensweise festhalten weil
die chinesische regierung aber gezielt
tausende von han-chinesen in der stadt
ansiedelt fühlt sich die uiguren stark
bedrängt diesen uigurischen
kupferschmied lässt man allerdings als
touristenattraktion gewähren
ich versuche mich an unserem doll
menschen vorbei zu verständigen
die uiguren möchten mehr autonomierechte
becken aber will ihnen dieser nicht
gewähren wie erlebter dass die regierung
ist ihr ein stein und wir sind wie ein
ei kann nichts gegen ein stein
ausrichten wenn die regierung was
unbedingt will müssen wir uns dem fügen
ich will nicht dass sie mein haus
abreißen er möchte selbst renovieren
aber dazu fehlt ihnen das geld und wenn
er die staatliche unterstützung in
anspruch nimmt so werden seine
eigentumsrechte eingeschränkt wenn man
vom staat geld für die renovation nimmt
dann ist man nur noch mit besitzer
seines hauses 60 prozent gehören dann
dem staat und nur noch 40 prozent mir
selbst und die inneneinrichtung wurde
nochmals sehr viel geld verschlungen
das können sich nicht alle leisten dass
unser gespräch von drei behördlichen
aufpassern überwacht wird die auf diesen
aufnahmen nicht zu sehen sind scheint
der große schmid gelassen hinzunehmen
hier schießt ein neuer roboter kongress
komplex in die höhe
hier werden büro neue wohnhäuser für
chinesen gebaut die aus dem sogenannten
in china nach kashgar umgesiedelt werden
wir besuchen das baubüro der
immobilienfirma macht es wirklich sinn
die halbe stadt umzupflügen wir haben
hier schon jetzt zehntausende neue
arbeitsplätze geschaffen und solche
werden hier dringend benötigt es fehlt
aber auch ein großes einkaufszentrum mit
unserem großprojekt das shanghai
versorgen wir kashgar mit besseren mit
luxuriöseren angeboten china verharrt
zum teil zu sehr im privaten
landwirtschaftsbereich unsere zukunft in
der stadt den großen chinesischen
bauprojekten müssen immer mehr jüdische
leben häuser weichen und außerhalb der
stadt in uiguren die tiere halten dabei
das ohnehin spärlich fließende wasser
immer knapper
der viehmarkt von kaspar ist legendär
immer sonntags bringen die chorischen 40
darauf dagegen die ihre tiere hierher
das verhandeln hier auf dem markt ist
männersache
[Musik]
ihr gerecht nach unserem verständnis
werden die schafe und ziegen die hier
zum verkauf angeboten werden aber nicht
fest gebunden
[Musik]
naja
von kaschgar fahrig dem südlichen rand
der taklamakan wüste entlang in die
uigurische stadt roten deren demütig
dargestellt nur uhren die hand reicht
symbol der han chinesischen dominanz
und dann war einst das bedeutendste
zentrum der seidenweberei in einem
vorort wert nach traditioneller art
applus seite gefärbt und zu stoffbahnen
gewogen
früher haben wir die raupen selbst
gezüchtet werden selbst gemacht heute
bekommen wir diese aus dem inneren china
zugeliefert aufgrund eines dekrets der
chinesischen regierung wussten viele
maulbeerbäume die natürliche
lebensgrundlage der seidenraupen neuen
baumwollplantagen weichen und die
seidenraupen sie werden jetzt in
fabriken gezüchtet wir lieben unseren
beruf und geben unser wissen immer
wieder unseren kindern weiter
die sauerstoffproduktion ist unsere
lebensgrundlage
[Musik]
die uiguren in dieser region leben in
ihrer eigenen welt
parallel zur kultur und wirtschaftsweise
des offiziellen china
angesicht der expansion der han chinesen
aber ist es für die muslimischen uiguren
mich ganz einfach ihre traditionen zu
bewahren
nach dem färben in kalten und heißen
bädern werden die getrockneten strenge
auf einer in die jahre gekommenen
weltmaschine zu seiten bahnen verboten
typische muster denen man fast überall
im westlichen teil der seitenstraße
begegnen
es ist abend und alle versammeln sich im
hof die ganze familie stolz bringt uns
meinte torri diako dollar eine auswahl
frisch gebot noch seidentücher in ja
gefallen diese muster die festtagskleid
ligurische frauen schmücken
ich reise weiter in die oasenstadt dünn
war einst reichsten vor allem
seitenstraßen händler
um diese frühesten stadt heute der drang
vor allem von touristen aufgesucht der
bank gehört zu den top ten unter den
reisezielen chinas
[Musik]
herr 25 jahren führte die regierung
bezahlte urlaubstage 1
seither boomt der tourismus und die
oasenstadt panka seidenstraße kann sich
kaum mehr retten vor dem ansturm der
neuen chinesischen mittelklasse die
touristen suchen hier aber nicht die
einsamkeit der wüste was offenbar vor
allem zählt dass das kollektive erleben
man wolle spüren dass man als chinese
nie alleine sei heißt es
wie fühlt sich dieses junge paar mitten
in diesem massentourismus china ist sehr
groß wir haben viele verschiedene
kulturen
wir sind hier und touristen aus allen
gegenden chinas zu treffen
wir verstehen uns untereinander sehr gut
das reisen trägt dazu bei dass wir uns
noch besser kennenlernen
[Musik]
für mich ist es ein überwältigendes
erlebnis mich allein auf diesen
sanddünen zu bewegen
überall nur fand feinster sand
[Musik]
auf der weiterfahrt begegne ich riesigen
windenergieanlagen hier wird deutlich
dass china längst auch den alternativ
energien zugewandt hat
[Applaus]
eineinhalb millionen menschen wohnen
hier in der stadt chania schon marco
polo soll auf seiner reise hier
eingekehrt sein
china hat in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten eine einzige aktive
binnenmigration lebt in der hoffnung auf
einträgliche arbeit in der industrie
sind etwa 300 millionen chinesen in die
städte gezogen weg vom land wie zb aus
dem bezirk schon dann in der nähe von
chania landwirtschaft prägt auf 2300
metern höhe das café leben von chinas
fortschritt ist hier nichts zu spüren
zum auszeiten wurden hier noch pferde
für die rote armee gezüchtet bauern
jumping ist hier geboren seine eltern
wirkten während der kulturrevolution als
stallknecht der auf dem verfahren holm
auf deutsch rotes baby ist fans stolz
und gleichzeitig auch sein einziger
besetzt als mitarbeiter der pferde
fahren werde niemals teil seines lohnes
ein raum zum schlafen und wohnen und
eine spärlich eingerichtete küche zur
verfügung gestellt zum leben reicht dies
jedoch nicht
im sommer hofft hahn jumping auf
touristen welche zum reiten auf die
abgelegene fahren kommen
im unterschied zum grünen park von jin
wang aber finden nur wenige touristen
hierher
heute hat man glück ein paar aus dem
fernen heller nicht erreichen
was den bauern selbstverständliches
natur frische luft und ruhe ist genau
das was die vergleichsweise gut
gestellten touristen auf chinas
millionenmetropolen hier suchen
[Musik]
für drei stunden freiheit bezahlen die
beiden touristen umgerechnet rund 40
franken fährt er für ihre panis
zufrieden mit seinem heutigen
zusatzverdienst
doch die scheinbare idylle trügt auf pan
und seine frau wollen nicht auf dem land
bald werden sie träumen von modernen
leben in der großstadt
[Musik]
ich habe genug von diesem harten leben
ich habe es mehr als satt ich will weg
hier
ich sehne mich nach einer veränderung
ich will nicht nur eine neue umgebung
sondern auch einen neuen lebensstil kann
möchte sein pferd sein einziges hab und
gut verkaufen und sich so bald wie
möglich für immer in die stadt auf
machen
und ich fahre weiter südostwärts sind
die chinesische industrie und großstadt
land am gelben fluss
[Musik]
während sieben stunden bin ich nachts
mit der bahn unterwegs
unsere lage ist mit passagieren so
vollgestopft dass einige gezwungen sind
zu stehen
zum schlafen komme ich kaum
auch wer über einen reservierten
sitzplatz verfügt muss diesen stets
verteidigung
[Musik]
am frühen morgen reiche ich die kein
halbmillionenstadt
[Musik]
seit über 2000 jahren das land schon
bedeutender knotenpunkt an dem wichtige
verkehrswege den gelben fluss queren den
zweitlängsten strom tinas
[Musik]
viele chinesen frühstücken jeweils in
einem restaurant
vermittelnd rindfleisch hier diesem
restaurant lerne ich lehrerin
schwankungen ihrer tochter die 16
jährige schülerin martin hug nennen die
ich einen vormittag lang begleiten darf
die berühmten und scharf gewürzten
landschule lang nudeln genieße ich
vorsichtig cheyrou ist eine gute
schülerin trotzdem büffelt sie während
ihrer sommerferien an einer privatschule
um in drei jahren das berichtet dekker
ob zu bestehen die übertritts prüfung
die hochschule freizeit gibt es kaum
das sind keine popstar fand und jungen
engagierten lehrer dieser privatschule
viele kennt wohl das härteste
schulsystem der welt für viele beginnt
der schultag morgens um halb acht und
endet spät abends um elf
was ist denn penrose lebenstraum hängt
wirklich alles nur von der schule ab ich
möchte andere länder und kulturen
kennenlernen
es gibt dinge die wichtiger sind als das
was man in der schule lernt der
konkurrenzkampf ist hart die zukunft in
china gehört die fleißigen auch der
preis den sie dafür zahlen ist oben
wegen des stresses nehmen immer mehr
studenten auch psychologische hilfe in
anspruch wie eine klassenkameradin von
jenni
sie selbst hat eltern die sie nicht
unter einen unerträglichen
erwartungsdruck setzen
dies ist offenbar eher eine seltenheit
beim lernen haben wir großen druck der
druck liegt uns aber auch nicht
aufzugeben das ist ebenfalls wichtig im
leben manchmal ist es hier schwierig
aber es hilft uns unsere träume zu
erreichen
nach der englische sturm den haben mich
jambou und ihre mutter zu sich nach
hause ein
dort ist auch die großmutter eine
muslimische chinesen zu besuch
als mutter versucht johann ihrer tochter
freiräume und zeit zum entspannen zu
geben und auch als lehrerin spricht
offen über die problematischen aspekte
des chinesischen bildungssystems für
mich ist die große prüfung nicht das
wichtigste im leben
sie verursacht so viel stress die
kindheit und viel potenzial gehen
verloren
die schüler verbessern zwar ihr peak
wissen aber andere talente und die
sozialkompetenz werden nicht entwickelt
doch dieser harte prüfung können sie an
die uni aber auch dort lernen sie nicht
für das wirkliche leben
die herzliche begegnung gebrauchter
leistungswille von cherno mich
beeindruckt die resultate der
chinesischen leistungsbereitschaft so
denke ich mir werden wir im westen in
unserer wohlfühlgesellschaft noch sehr
stark zu spüren bekommen
jetzt starte ich zur letzten etappe von
der stadt land tue in die einstige
chinesische kaiser starb sie an
erkannt ist spanischer seine stadtmauer
und auch für seine riesigen grünanlagen
ich bin im revolutionstag der stadt bei
strömenden regen decke ich interessante
anzeigen und treffe vor allem ältere
menschen
[Musik]
bei uns kaum vorstellbar eltern
montieren am park bäumen selbst
gebastelte annoncen in denen sie für
ihren sohn eine passende lebenspartnerin
suchen
wegen der ein-kind-politik unter
zahlreichen abtreibungen von denen vor
allem weibliche föten betroffen sind
leider china unter einem enormen
frauenmangel die rede ist von rund 30
millionen frauen ein schüchterner sohn
kommt nicht selbst aus angst vor
gesichtsverlust dieser vater preis
seinen angeblich vielbeschäftigten sohn
gleich selbst dann und hinterfragt
ansprüche der jüngeren generation heute
verlangen die jungen leute sehr viel
[Musik]
sie hatten ganz genaue vorstellungen
puncto alter aussehen größe ausbildung
beruf einkommen wohnort mit solch hohen
ansprüchen ist es natürlich sehr
schwierig eine wirklich passende
partnerin zu finden
dann treffe ich mit unserer chinesisch
dolmetscherin eine frau und einen mann
die zu geben
für sich selbst nach einer partnerschaft
ausschau zu halten
die beiden scheinen sich auch
sympathisch zu sein doch das eis unter
chinesen schmilzt weniger schnell als
bei uns wenn sie diese frau mögen dann
sagen sie es ihr doch einfach und wie
gefällt ihnen dieser mann sieg glücklich
über dieses treffen
ja ja sympathisch aus wollen sie sich
nicht mal unverbindlich treffen einfach
zu einer tasse tee oder ich habe eine
dünne haut
ich habe angst den ersten schritt zu
machen
und der zweite schritt ist noch viel
schwieriger
meine etwas ungelenken bemühungen als
partnervermittler haben nicht sofort
gefruchtet aber vielleicht springt bei
den beiden an einem anderen sonntag doch
noch der funke über
[Musik]
während man in china allzu persönliches
lieber zurückhält betont man weltliches
gerne und stolz etwa hier in der
grabanlage des ersten chinesischen
kaisers qin shi huangdi seine
weltberühmte terrakotta-armee bastian
gehört zu den allerwichtigsten
sehenswürdigkeiten chinas
vor über 2200 jahren schuf sich kaiser
ganze streitmacht aus ton die ihm nach
seinem tod schutz vor allfälligen
feinden aus dem jenseits gewähren sollte
jede einzelne figur ist individuell
gestaltet
vor allem deren anzahl ist überwältigend
7000 soldaten 600 pferde zahlreiche
kriegs wagen und posse waffen
dies ist der chinesische kaiser hat er
gilt dem osten als begründer der
seidenstraße sein credo lautete naja
guten für den warentransport politische
kontakte und kultureller austausch denn
so meinte er
um innerlich zu wachsen müsse der mensch
die welt akku liegen
was ist die wichtigste errungenschaft
der seitenstraße die freiheit frei zu
denken
freiheit bedeutet ein inneres und
äußeres ziel erreichen hemmung
beseitigen barrieren öffnen ohne die
kommunikation mit anderen kulturen gebe
es keinen globalen geist keine
gedankenfreiheit nur dunkelheit die
seidenstraße hat den menschen den
horizont erweitert die seidenstraße sei
so etwas wie die motor der
globalisierung mein professor die bei
uns am abschließenden rundgang über den
marktforschern
die freundlichen parkbesucher reichen
wir einen wasser pinsel und ich lasse
dabei innerlich unsere reise revue
passieren
bei uns und begegnungen in südeuropa in
der türkei im kaukasus und zentralasien
und hier in china habe ich stets gespürt
wie verschieden die welten sind wie hier
die menschen dinge oft unterschiedlichen
senden
dem äußerst wichtigen austausch auf den
routen der seitenstraße verdanken wir
dass wir uns in diesen verschiedenen
kulturkreisen trotzdem nicht ganz fremd
sind
wir haben gelernt aufeinander zuzugehen
und uns besser zu verstehen
und dies ist vielleicht das bewegendste
was mir zum abschluss unserer
wundervollen reise in großer dankbarkeit
zu sagen
[Musik]